[Music]
foreign
I can't go back in time and fix all the
mistakes I made
but maybe I could leave something for
the future
[Music]
a legacy
the world is on fire
I decided to do something about it
oops dreams Ambitions the mission was to
protect their world
and Ours
that's what we wanted Monarch to be
instead of chasing monsters
if you come with me you'll know
everything I promise
[Music]
foreign
thank you
years ago I was basically unemployed
Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way I'm
not either pops my job was a little less
stressful than yours
foreign
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people
every known species in the sea
call this place home
that doesn't mean they all like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds dear
I'm gonna murder his family
burn his
to Ash
he must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might go to help
us
who you look rough
good job brother high five do not call
me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job through
king-built Bridges right
build Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
doing King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
or curse upon them all
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
can't leave our children a world without
hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
the Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever
it is
[Music]
go to ya
my NASA
[Music]
ETA five minutes to the war zone we must
thank you
[Music]
foreign
I have a job for you a piece of cake
really
good
it's a security gig
hello
welcome to Freddy's have you met them
yet
Bonnie
chica Freddy
back in the 80s
some kids went missing what is this why
the place shut down the can we search
Freddy's hey they never found the kids
[Music]
ghost children
possessing giant robots
tell me how to stop them you don't it's
too late
he's coming
[Music]
the mecca a program is complete our
Target a chemical weapons Factory full
address
turn their own water machine against
them
the mega ape is in motion lesbian
mannequins
Madame deputy secretary McCafe has been
activated outside of our control we saw
what Abraham and that lizard did in
Washington DC push well down far enough
to reach the breaking point the Mecha
ape is a walking Arsenal make sure that
thing doesn't reach Chicago
we got another Washington DC in our
hands we need to fight this with an
appropriate response
we'll send the eight
we can help her okay now
the workout has been taken there's a
live Warhead on board Evacuate the city
immediately
laughs
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Jonas
we need your help
we're detecting increased aquatic
activity 25 000 feet deep in the trench
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
men whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
that's the biggest night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody make it to the station
three massive exit who knows what else
can escape the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
I Don't Wanna Know
[Applause]
you've never seen this before they
hunted it back
you can relax this place is Meg proof
majorness was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking
[Music]
oh barracuda
I have dreams sometimes about things
that will happen
and I wake up terrified
spare death destruction
this is even bigger than the last crisis
[Music]
an Empire breathes respect
it requires it for its life the
foundation is a threat to me
I will look at them in the eye and
reclaim what is ours
for all of us to survive we have to face
them we need to be in the fight
we fight for peace
not because we fear we will lose
but because we know
that if there is war
you can win
[Music]
we are taking the planet
this time you and I had a reckoning
[Music]
the Demeter
on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
content unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
okay
he's a doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay upon
us for timely arrival in London
let me show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give the
use clear
[Applause]
something ripped about the elements
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it rings our blood he's just
here
we call him Dracula
he's coming
see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
oh
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
[Music]
Becca Oh I thought we were boys
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
oh
yeah
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
this world is beyond cruelty
you've been fighting the Harkins for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
your father didn't believe in Revenge
[Music]
let me fight beside you
reload
he said that I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
[Music]
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
Prophet why is that a bad thing use it
because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paula trades are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
foreign
[Music]
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]
but it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn win
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure got a Bus full of prisoners heading
our way got caught in the storm and need
a place to hunker down until it's safe
watch on your best behavior while we're
here
straight you're in my house now I will
not hesitate to shoot you if I have to
y'all don't think this is cruel and
unusual right here
you tell me how an alligator got in your
damn police station the storm brought
him in could be infested with him by now
if you want to survive the night we're
gonna have to find a way to get along
keep an eye on him that's a Bonafide cop
kill it right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
he got one shot Sheriff
here to taste like chicken
[Music]
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
and I tried to talk him out of it you
read it out
don't use that word that way I mean
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
this is insane Squirtle mutant karate
teams I want to know everything about
you our dad is definitely not a giant
rat that makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit
cooler foot and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
tough talk I dream about fighting every
night you you're great it's not a
problem
Harper has his first new zombie movie
coming out in over 30 years no one knows
anything about it except it'll Premiere
here exclusively in carverville
Halloween night
is the projector ready
[Music]
no start the movie
what is this
you just roll the film and it turns the
actors into the Living Dead
power to suck the souls out of everyone
in this vicinity we can stop them from
spreading as Marion had all the
knowledge if he were here he'd know what
to do your films must be burnt you have
to destroy them all go to the theater
stop the projector that's the last film
no freaking way
I just got my driver's license you can
drive
[Applause]
away from it
[Music]
brought something and hit him on the
head
[Music]
we'll never watch another zombie movie
again
hurry up
what take it off
[Music]
oh God can you drive
have you seen my kid
means they've been home an hour ago your
mom's gonna be very upset with you
I love your costume which right oh it's
not a costume I was sweeping the floor
okay fine one month detention please
[Music]